hey there my name is Danny wrench I'm a
chess master and this video is an
autocomplete of the web's most searched
for chess terms alright here we go I
don't even know what the first chess
term will be why is chess ok why is
chess so hard that is a very good
question and you are looking at the
poster child for the game was too hard
for me
no but jokes aside chess is hard chess
is hard because it's a game of pattern
recognition and it takes time to to see
enough patterns that you can recognize
them and speak the language I always
think chess is a little bit more
comparable to mastering a language than
maybe other things than people realize
and it can take a lot of time and if you
don't learn it at a young age sometimes
it can be even harder to learn a
language but just as hard because it
takes time to to recognize what you're
looking at and you got a practice so in
practice every day
I guess I'd say what else we got here
why is chess a sport now that's an
interesting question I think some people
would actually disagree that chess is a
sport I think chefs is a sport it is a
competition where you you have to best
someone else in order to win and to me
it's it's a sporting activity because
that's what I think of when I think of
those sports you're trying to outplay
and out my new 4 out think I'll attack
right out out physically you know
overpower another human being even if
it's not physical you have to do all
those things on a chess board in order
to beat somebody else so I think just as
a sport let's keep it going
why is chess a boys chest called chess I
actually don't know the answer to that I
know that chess originates from the game
chaturanga which dates back as far as
600 AD and is literally one of the
oldest games in the history of the
universe the name of the game evolved
over time we know that some languages
it's called shock Matsu ahkamaat in
russia's is because shock like the word
shock means king and and the king is in
check know what I'm talking about I
don't know why it's called chess I'm
ready for the next question
here we go all right what's next where
is chess okay where's chess most popular
that that's an interesting question I
think that now the right
answer is online that's actually a funny
answer but it's the truth because you
can see millions of chess games being
played everywhere on the interwebs I
would say that historically you would
say that the chess culture is most
popular in the Soviet Union and in
Eastern Europe these days chess is
booming in China obviously India over
the last 20 years with Vishwanath on and
on there's a world champion so the short
answer is just as most popular online
and that's actually changing the culture
of chess meaning someone in even the
most remote countries of the world all
our countries like Norway they didn't
have a very strong chess history to
speak up before Magnus Carlsen are now
thriving and maybe in some ways one of
the chest capitals of Europe right if
you think of Norway so chess is chess is
popular everywhere it is my answer and
hopefully that suffice is alright let's
go where what do we got next where is
chess the musical play is is there a
musical called chess there me is there
chess musical - check that out it's in
my head just the musical is in my head
where did chess originate from so I
actually answered that in the why is
chess again the earliest versions of the
game called shattering a date back to
600 AD it actually moved from India
across Asia and into eventually Eastern
Europe and Western Europe during during
the the the the rise and fall of the
Persian Empire Alexander the Great among
the the leaders conquerors dictators
whatever you want to call those back
then but he was he was part of taking
some of the earliest versions of the
game that were played in India and
moving them west so to speak so at least
that's what the legend tells the modern
game as we play it today really really
came together in the medieval times the
14th 15th century Queen Isabella of
Spain was actually the lady at the time
maybe the most powerful human being on
the planet who decided that the Queen
would not be a bystander and that she
would be the most powerful piece on the
board so the game we play today kind of
originated around them on passant
followed not too far after the Queen's
powers were invoked by lady Isabella but
but the original versions of Jeff stayed
back as far as 600 AD in India so there
you go can chess can chess can chess pie
go back
is a chess by sign be up chess PI can
not go bad I'll say that can chest drive
you crazy and have you not seen the
long-winded answers I've given for the
first few starts to this video obviously
not dealing with a full deck here the
answer is yes let's continue can chess
grandmasters be computers so not anymore
unfortunately we used to be able to but
chess grandmasters can no longer be
computers they are the top chess players
on the planet even if they're not humans
they are the top chess players the stock
fish the Leela's the alpha 0 is the
Komodos of the world are our
artificially intelligent or overlords
and I for one welcome them can't wait
for more is chess is chess in the
Olympics Ohno fidei has tried for a very
long time to put it officially in the
Olympics there is a chess Olympian but
it is not a part of the IOC s governed
Olympics unfortunately so sorry that's
the answer to that one is chess or
checkers harder I'm not even gonna
answer that question if you don't know
the answer to that question
keep playing checkers I'm sorry I got so
offended by that question there's no
what happen to me
it's just psychically demanding that's
not psychologically that's psychic
though physically I can't read is chess
knows psychically demanding I I don't I
don't know that I've ever had to use my
psychic powers when playing chess I do
have them but I haven't ever had to use
them so I'm gonna say no chess is not
psychically demanding and we continue
here is chess is chess dangerous I don't
think just as dangerous like that let's
keep going is chess it's just good for
ADHD it actually is it actually has been
shown to improve your focus I think I'm
not a doctor but I do host chess TV
shows where I pretend to know things
like the answers to those questions
I think chess is good for ADHD you heard
it here first okay where we got is chess
his chest for nerds some have said that
chess players are the kings of the Nerds
okay that we're like the quarterbacks of
the Nerds like the cool kid in high
school and I don't even know that you'd
want to be the cool guy in high school
beware the late bloomer beware the
underdog right
most people who peak in high school are
probably watching these videos on the
internet let's be honest and we continue
here on this journey is chess we got
more is chess is chest just memorization
so contrary to popular belief it's not
actually and what I will say is that the
best chess players have memorized ideas
ideas and patterns because ideas and
patterns repeat so when you memorize
that you're almost memorizing hundreds
of potential positions because that
pattern that idea can be applied in a
future position even chess players who
memorize very very deep opening lines
are not winning games because of chess
memorization I can tell you that chess
is not just memorization so we continue
is chess like tic-tac-toe ok did sue put
you put someone out to do put you up to
that one chess is not like tic-tac-toe
whatever who okay continue please all
right apparently we have a little more
is chess is chess is a popular term
right it's just boxing a real sport it
is a real sport that doesn't mean it's a
popular sport it's trying and and you
know maybe in some dark circles of Tyler
Durden house chess boxing is thriving
okay but why wasn't just boxing a thing
in Fight Club god I miss you Tyler okay
continuing here we go is chess is chess
all natural talent it is definitely not
I would say it is mostly mostly hard
work it's difficult because sometimes
you see somebody who's 610 and can jump
through the roof and you say well he's
more naturally talented than me to
potentially play basketball right I mean
possibly and it's harder for us to
measure the brain because we can't
physically see it at least as human
beings that's how we kind of measure
things with our eyes and that way so I
would say there's definitely there has
to be parts of certain people's brains
and and whatever their their genetic
makeup that makes them have a have a
potentially higher aptitude
for chess should they ever be exposed to
the game so maybe there's some natural
things there that certain people would
have that others don't but I think even
with that being the case overall chess
is hard work and practice no thing it's
just a chess it's raw well we are trying
to find out we as in chess human beings
are artificially intelligent overlords
right they're battling all the time you
know I think a lot of people have said
that when chess is solved they will be
proven to be a draw so for the most part
we assume a perfect game means it will
end in equality I think that's probably
going to be the case but the truth is we
don't know yet whether chess is a is a
draw or not probably in my lifetime
we'll find out and and traditional
classical chess might be solved and then
you know we'll be doing other different
variants of it but maybe not so um I
don't know I don't know the answer to
that but I hope to find out no more is
chess who does chess uh-huh now we're
getting spicy does chess change your
brain um don't know does just change
your brain I don't know I think it I
think it can help critical thinking and
we you know we know that it's good for
kids and cognitive development and
apparently fights Alzheimer's helps with
memory loss but I don't know if it
physically changes your brain does chess
make you lose weight that's interesting
you know i would i would probably say
inherently no in the sense that if
you're sitting down physically but also
you burn a lot of calories when you're
super focused mental energy mental
exertion mental exhaustion burns
calories as much as physical does now
depending on the physical activity
you're doing right versus the mental
activity physical activity can burn more
but I do know that you burn calories and
sometimes significant ones during long
and grueling chess game so in a way yeah
here we go here we go does chest'
relate to math chess in a lot of ways is
math right you have to calculate the
value of what you're getting versus what
you're losing ultimately you are
constantly making decisions of whether
you're gaining more value than you're
giving there is a lot of you know
calculated risk assessment that goes
into chess which is kind of a different
type of math
I would say just relates to math in a
lot of different ways and we continue we
continue we continue what is what is
life what is quantum chess quantum chess
is a fantastic video Google that term
and go down that rabbit hole yourself I
don't want to spoil it for you let's
let's do that so what is what is what is
a tempo in chess a tempo is when you
gain time and you often do this by
attacking a piece when you attack
something valuable and your opponent has
to defend it as long as it's part of a
greater plan is said to have been a move
that gained a tempo it gained a tempo
and it was useful for you
what is chess hustling chess hustling is
when you pretend to be worse than you
are you pretend to be underrated and not
that good and so you trick people into
maybe throwing a few bucks something in
the game right you can Google different
videos Maurice Ashley chess hustling in
the park right chess hustling is was
kind of made famous originally in the
movie searching for Bobby Fischer with
the chess hustlers in Washington Square
Park which is a real thing but it's not
as easy to do as you might think these
days because people are often suspicious
of a chess hustler and we continue we
continued and oh my gosh here we go all
right
what is Daniel drenches net worth first
of all do we even know the answer to
that question cuz I'd like to know what
is it what is my net worth I don't know
I honestly don't know I have four kids
so you know what's going down
it's dwindling I'll tell you that much
and they're not even in college yet what
is Dana brunch is net worth I don't know
I'd like to find out what day is this is
that thing yeah I'm alive I think so is
is this the matrix I mean or any of us
truly alive I am Alive at least at the
time and recording of this video let's
hope it stays that way can't wait for my
next one why is Daniel brunch important
well I I'm not but if if you wanted a
white I think I'm important I do things
that just come I have a wife and four
children please don't eat me what's next
here we go can chess reduce stress well
not for this guy I'll tell you that much
you know if you can't tell from the bags
my eyes the the balding and the stress
wait I'm carrying around I know of
course chess can reduce stress chess is
an amazing distraction in some ways I
have been told that obviously it's great
for critical thinking not just for young
people cognitive development but also
for fighting off memory loss and
Alzheimer's and things like that so I
know that there are a lot of things
inherently about the game of chess your
approach to kind of the consequences of
your actions thinking ahead that are
fantastic for people reducing stress
getting stressed answer this let's move
on I don't know if it reduces stress can
somewhat help me reduce my stress and
answering that question coz chest raise
your I mean I just kind of answered that
question right chess for young people
husband has been shown and related to a
lot of studies on young young people who
performed well in school score well on
tests right I don't know for sure
whether chess has ever been proven to
raise your IQ I think it's I think it's
been proven to at least be helpful for
critical thinking and like I said a lot
of studies showing now it does fight off
memory loss so that's cool but it this
particular question is getting stressful
well I can't chess can just be done now
can we move on why are these two
questions bothering me can just make you
rich I'll tell you that obviously some
chess businesses have done very well a
lot of people have said that
professional chess players struggle if
you're outside of the top twenty to
thirty in the world it's very difficult
to make a living just as a pure player
there are the world's elite players who
are commanding super large appearance
fees playing for very big prize funds
and being supported very well by those
looking to invest in chess but I think
that chess I will say this has proven to
have more of a stable business model for
those who are willing to invest the time
into to coaching to running after-school
enrichment programs to building sort of
a business around people's desire to
learn the game whether everybody can
make it as a player I would probably
have to save right now in the current
landscape probably not but we're hoping
to change that and we invest all the
time and in big chess events and that's
not just us I'm spaying we is in the
global chess organizing world right not
just people at chess calm so let's hope
that the answer to that someday is chess
made a few people rich
and they did good things with that money
well apparently that's it apparently
we've gone through this whole webs most
search for chess terms autocomplete
edition hopefully you liked it if you
did leave us leave us a comment down low
let us know if there were some other
chess terms you were hoping to get
answers to otherwise give us a like a
share and subscribe all those things we
do appreciate it
anyway this is a lot of fun and hope to
do it again sometime